hey how's it going in it Samuel leads
here we're here at the country mansion
and I just wanted to give a video to you
guys because he's coming very close to
the deal finding extravaganza and our
zero program I just want to say I've had
a lot of people come to me and say that
they want to be part of that program and
there's becoming to move three four five
thousand pounds to try and attempt and
all I have told them no we're sold out
because I said that with 15 people max
so we have got 15 people and all of
those are from the crash course the
first thing we're going to be covering
is how to source properties on deal
finding extravaganza
now people pay us regularly 2,000 pounds
for us to find the property for them
you're gonna learn that skill of whether
you want to find properties for yourself
or if you want to pass them on you will
have that scale of the deal finding
extravaganza it's a fabulous day and I'm
really excited about it we then have two
days of zero training zero the zero
program is just absolutely incredible
we've had people attend this program
find lease option agreement over the two
days and either keep them and have a
house for free or pass them on for four
five thousand pound fees so that is just
incredible so the second thing you learn
is how to find and secure lease option
agreement no money down deals and then
the third thing that we're going to be
going through is how to be a deal source
or how to package deals up and pass them
on a for a fee you're gonna have so much
opportunity on that three days so much
learning so much practice now as part of
the deal well I did say that you would
have a little bit of one-to-one coaching
as well so I'd love to set up a coaching
call with you I've got a little bit of
time available what you want to include
and a link somewhere or on this email
somewhere but I'd love to set up a
coaching call with you so I can get you
prepared for the three days and get you
doing the right things right now
so on the course you'll be able to
really get the most out of it maximize
your time from it you know what I mean
the stuff that you're going to be
getting from the three
is the investment that you paid I expect
you to get that back within weeks and
then you'll have a lifelong skill
they'll be able to replace your income
help me become financially independent
you will be a property expert where
people will paying you soon to teach
them how to do these skills so if you're
excited let me know please do book your
coaching call with me real soon I am so
excited to be working with you there's
going to be so much opportunity laid out
and this is going to be a fabulous year
I can't wait to see you on the 18th 19th
and 20th of May at the Holiday Inn
Express in Warsaw god bless your season
I'm actually shaking I'm so excited
[Music]